Dr. Peterson.
Thank you for coming.
We all,
uh,
appreciate it a lot.
Uh,
I wanted to get your opinion on
censorship that we're seeing on the web.
Uh,
it's accelerating.
You were a very notable example.
You were locked out of your
Gmail and B and Trump account.
Pardon me?
Oh yeah.
Trump just got a deleted
by an air in person,
you know,
now they're saying that perhaps this
was just a contractor and you know,
maybe,
uh,
someone from Twitter who's gone
in a very far left direction,
uh,
youtube has gone in a
very far left erection.
Uh,
I'm just wondering,
I've started a,
an alternative to youtube called Pew Tube.
Uh,
what kind of,
um,
what,
what do you see for possible solutions
and just your thoughts in general or is
it not?
Here's an
crazy thought,
but I'm going to tell it to you anyways.
Sorry.
I was just reading one
of Ray Kurzweil's books,
I think it was called,
how to make a mind.
I really liked it actually.
It helped me understand how the brain
compresses information because the world
is really complicated,
so you have to make a low resolution
representation of it to live in it.
And he actually explained to me in a way
that I hadn't really understood how the
brain might do that neurologically.
So that was cool.
But you know,
Kurt's while this guy who
thinks that he's a smart guy,
a very smart guy and uh,
he's invented a fair bit of high
end technical technological,
uh,
software and hardware and he's the guy
that thinks that we're heading towards
the singularity.
And so the singularity is,
you know,
how processing speed doubles every 18
months and like hard disk capacity every
year and there's a bunch
of doublings going on,
a huge number of them and
they accelerate exponentially.
And so it's probably,
we're probably three years away,
maybe even less then from
building a computer that has,
is the capacity to make
as many calculations as
reasonable estimates of the
calculating capacity
of the human brain are,
are currently set up 18 months away,
two years away,
something like that.
And then we're 18 months away from having
one that's twice that fast and then 18
months away from having one
that's twice as fast as that.
So that's like say six years
and we've got something that's eight
times as smart as a human being.
But there's a twist on that.
And this is Kurt swells twist,
which is as soon as you make a machine
smart enough to make the next machine
that's smarter than it,
which is sort of what we're doing because
computers are so fast that that will
scale up to near infinite computing
computing power almost instantaneously.
Now you think?
No,
probably not.
And Allen,
Bob Gates partner has written critiques
of Kurtzweil while and you know,
you might think if something's impossible
then it won't even if you don't know
why.
And there's reasons to not
think that that will happen.
But Kurzweil's traced back the doubling
of computing power way before the
existence of the transistor and
it's been ridiculously stable,
crazily stable.
So God only knows what
we're coming up with here.
You know,
and you don't know what something of
infinite computing power might be like.
Like you seriously don't know.
And there are serious people who are very,
very,
very worried about that.
They're very worried,
for example,
that companies like Facebook and
Google will manage that first.
And you know,
those companies are already
making censorship AI bots.
And that's what,
that's smart.
It's sort of like making really
fast robots that can shoot people.
It's not that smart.
And we're doing that to very rapidly.
And you know,
I know some guys who work in advanced
AI and you know how you look,
you watch the term terminator movies and
you see the robots that miss when they
shoot at you.
Like they're not very bright because the
bright ones not only shoot at where you
are,
but they estimate where you're going to
be when you make your escape moves and
they shoot their simultaneously and their
death rate is 100% and so there's no
war against the robots.
I mean,
when those things get going,
they're going to be so much faster than
us that will look like we're moving
through molasses to them.
So
you know,
so maybe what we're deciding now with
all of our individual decisions about
censorship and the way that we're going
to construct the world and all that is
exactly what kind of super intelligence
we're going to bring into being.
And I would suggest that we try to bring
one in that's good and moral rather
than one that's evil and demonic,
right?
So what can we do about that?
There's only one answer to that.
As far as I know that that
works is gay rock together.
You're going to be the
person who's working in Ai,
right?
I know some of these people,
they better be good people because they're
going to build whatever they're like
into their machines.
They better have their head screwed
on straight cause they're going to get
amplified like math.
And I don't like what's happening
with Google and Facebook and Youtube,
they're building censorship
bots predicated on a
certain kind of ideology and
the kind of ideology
that we outlined today.
It's a very bad idea.
Hopefully good people will stop that.
So then that,
what that means is that your
moral obligation is to be good.
And the way you do that is
first by stopping being bad.
And everyone can do that a little bit.
So I hope that's what
everyone does because the
consequences of not doing it are
not going to be pleasant.
They never are.
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
this question is about your
biblical lecture series.
Um,
I liked that one because
it's about genesis,
which is usually ignored as being,
we're this post enlightenment society,
you don't need these
ancient creation myths.
And also I thought revelations kind
of gets the same treatment as being
dismissed because it's the
crazy hallucinogenic trip.
That's why some isolated mad man
in the middle of the Mediterranean.
So I was wondering if after
you're done with genesis,
if you were thinking
about doing revelations,
not without traversing the,
the geography in between.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want to walk through the whole thing
if I can do that before I expire.
So,
I mean,
I've read it and thought about
it and it's such a strange book,
a because it's really big among
the evangelical Republican
types and you'd think
really,
really that's the book that's,
but you're relying on,
have you read it?
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's a crazy hallucinogenic trip.
That's what revelation is now.
That's not to play it down because God
only knows about crazy hallucinogenic
trips,
that's for sure.
I mean there's,
there's accruing evidence.
I would say that a tremendous amount
of the religious orientation of human
beings,
you know,
that deep mythological,
symbolic orientation is in no small
part a consequence of humanities
experimentation with
psychedelics substances.
I think that's,
that the evidence for that I think
has become virtually an overwhelming.
So
anyways,
I will get there.
Maybe,
probably not because at the rate
I'm going through the first stories,
it'll take me forever to get there.
Right.
But that's okay.
So thank you.
Yeah.
Dr. Peterson.
Thank you.
First of all,
it's great pleasure being here.
It's awesome to see you live.
Um,
I basically got into your work's just
earlier this year and I had an original
question,
but your talk today kind of made
me decide to change my mind.
I was going to ask,
um,
do you feel as though would you agree
with me and the sentiment that the left
has pushed so hard for total control of
our society over the last however many
years?
It's almost to a point where
saying 2013 was a different time.
Um,
would you say that because
they pushed so hard,
they've created this backlash
and the backlash created,
caused them to backlash back again.
So they doubled down with their
ideology and then they get,
they lose another argument.
They lose another ideological war.
They knew lose another me more and they
doubled down and they double down again
and again and they just
can't seem to meme,
they can't seem to argue.
They can't seem,
they can't,
they don't want to have an
intellectual discussion.
And as an interpretation
of what you were saying,
there is no,
there doesn't seem to be any,
any,
any care of what's right with them.
They just want power.
They just want,
they just want to win.
Um,
do you,
would you agree with the sentiment
that they're burning themselves out and
creating the mass red pilling of the,
uh,
conservative movement
that we see going on?
Would you possibly think to maybe
they've committed suicide and,
and talks like this,
people like yourself,
Ben Shapiro and others who talk to people
like what the subjects that we do the
taboo of nowadays,
um,
possibly that this,
this is the answer to defeat the,
the leftist strangle angle hold
it's on.
Our society will untangle some of that.
Okay.
So first of all,
well first of all,
the first observation is
a really interesting one
because you know that things
can go out of hand very,
very rapidly.
Yeah.
And the reason they do that is
because of positive feedback loops.
Now the thing that Kurzweil talks
about is a positive feedback loop.
And intelligent machine makes another
intelligent machine that makes another
intelligent machine.
And that's a positive feedback loop.
And that can spiral upwards
out of control very rapidly.
And that's when polarization is,
it's like,
I tap you,
you tap me,
I slapped you,
you punch me.
Well up it goes.
Well.
I think that's partly
why in the New Testament,
for example,
there's an injunction that
says turn the other cheek,
resist not evil.
Why?
Because otherwise you get into a positive
feedback loop and then you better look
the hell out and things can tilt very,
very rapidly.
I mean,
all you have to do,
look at what happened in World War one
new unexpected that it was like one,
one relatively minor member,
I think of the aristocracy,
if I remember correctly,
was assassinated in one
minor little country.
It's like bang,
everything fell apart.
And that's positive feedback loops,
right?
And so that's what we're in
right now and we've got to be,
and that's a really chaotic time.
And so I would say maintain self
control and don't aim to win.
Amen.
Peace.
Because winning,
that's,
that's not peace.
It's better to aim for peace.
You know,
I've got this talk coming up in November
11th I'm quite worried about it because
I know there's going to be protesters
there and that they've been emboldened by
the fact that they shut the talk down
before and I want to make a video.
I'll probably do it tomorrow,
telling everyone that comes
to that meeting to like
watch their bloody step and
stay out of the gutter because you just,
we're at,
we're at a point now where
under the wrong circumstances,
if the wrong person does the wrong thing,
that the consequences will be very great.
Now we can't predict which action is
going to precipitate that and or even if
that will happen,
but it's chaotic enough
so that it could happen.
So you know,
so govern yourselves accordingly.
Now the problem is is that there are
people who would be happy if there was
blood running in the street.
They're the same sort of people that
shoot up high schools or kill innocent,
you know,
elementary school kids just to show what
they're made of and what they believe.
And that's a big problem.
But for the rest of us,
like hopefully calmer heads can prevail.
And so it really is
important not to win it.
It's like fighting with your wife.
You don't win.
You can't because you have to live
with her because you can't win.
But maybe you can solve the
problem and bring about peace.
And so you've got to practice doing that.
Practice restraint.
And remember too,
that these people that you're talking
about who had radical leftists is most of
the time,
they're not like they're 95% like you.
And if you pull them out of the mob,
they're just like your,
your neighbor's 19 year old kid who's
kind of clueless and rebellious,
right.
And who you might even like
you put them in the mob.
It's a whole different thing.
And so you got to remember that too.
Oh,
this fear of social isolation,
kind of how they're acting,
how you say no,
it's just that they're
possessed by these ideas,
but,
but only partially,
you know,
you hardly find it full blooded.
Absolutely committed
radical leftist activist.
You know,
like there are some,
but not very many.
Most of it.
It's just fragmentary behavior.
And you have to remember that like when
the students come out to protest me was
a case,
particularly at McMaster,
have to remember these kids,
they're not much different than my kids.
They are when they're in a stupid
mob behind a hammer and sickle flag,
you know,
but,
but
you don't want to make a low resolution,
homogenous representation of them.
And so,
and so you,
that's why again,
I think instead of winning,
you turn to your own development.
You turn to your own development,
you do what you can to stop doing the
things that you're doing that aren't good
because you're not going to hurt anybody.
If you do that,
all you're going to do is help.
And otherwise you'll participate
in this polarization.
And that's unless you want that.
And you know,
there's a dark part of people that it's
part of the part that voted for Trump
would like to burn things to the ground.
It's like to hell.
I know how people felt when
they went into the voting booth.
It was like Hillary,
Hillary dealt with it.
Trump,
you know,
and that's,
that's a hell of a thing
to say to hell with it.
You know,
although I could,
I could certainly
understand that sentiment.
So we have to be careful and
all of you people who are here,
who are advocates of free speech and who
are theoretically happy to come hear me
speak.
It's like,
I really do believe in,
I truly believe this and this is something
I learned in part from social knits
and apart from y'all I that the way
that you set the world straight is by
constraining the malevolence
in your own heart.
And that's no joke,
man.
That's no easy thing and
that's a good voyage,
people to go on if they want something
difficult and worthwhile to do.
So thank you very much.
Okay,
just a quick thing.
Uh,
we're not going to have
time for pictures so you're,
unless you're,
yours is the last question.
Okay.
So sorry to everybody else,
but you're the last one.
Okay.
Hi,
doctor said,
thanks for coming.
Uh,
my question is a little bit off
topic from everything else tonight,
but I really wanted to hear
what you had to say about it.
Um.